>> From the Library of Congress
in Washington, D.C.
>> What is the legacy that you would
like to leave behind as an author?
>> Well, I think -- I guess
number one would be value history.
I do what I do, and I try to make history come
alive because I believe history makes you whole,
and I believe -- you know
it's that saying sankofa.
I think some people translate
it "go back and pick it up."
In Brooklyn, Reverend Johnny Ray Youngblood, his
translation is "The way out is back through."
So I feel for all people unless you
know your history, unless you go back,
you won't really come through whole.
When I was a kid -- see I
got like flashcard history.
It was like black people slaves
and then there was no more slavery
and then black people were ignorant.
It was like reconstruction was
a time where it was horrible
because some black men had
power and they messed up.
It was like there was nothing for me but shame,
violence, and knowing that I come from people
who weren't slaves, when I was
a kid I was kind of ashamed.
I was kind of embarrassed.
But through the work I've done I've learnt,
oh my God, I have nothing to be ashamed of.
I've been able to sort of do the
math and realize then say, "Wow."
Let's say -- take my grandfather.
He was a laborer in North Carolina.
If he was making -- I'm making 25 cents
a week or a day or whatever it was
and a white guy doing the same work, a
laborer was making 50 cents, I said, "Well,
then my grandfather had to be a genius
to raise his family on half the money,"
because both men had to buy cornmeal and
fatback or whatever for their families.
So that takes a genius to do that.
Also I started to realize that, okay, if I come
from enslaved people and Jim Crowed people,
they must have been kind of smart to produce
me because I don't see my accomplishments,
you know, the writing the books and the
[inaudible] and the Princeton and the Columbia,
I don't think that's just about me.
I think that says a lot about
the people I come from.
So I think, "My goodness.
Can you imagine if my grandfather had
my opportunities what he could have done
or my great grandfather?"
So I've found it's been my experience that
there was -- I say there is power in the past.
When you know the history, you are stronger
and just not your own ethnic racial
history, but the history of the country.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.